next with us in Seattle hi Nick how are
you hi Damon doing great thanks so much
for taking my call sure what's up so I'm
a young guy I'm 23 and I've been living
here platform for most of my life and
I'm trying to get into buying a house
with a no credit check but the problem
is I've lived I think a little too
debt-free there's no such thing
zero credit I'll or I mean your credit
score I have lived with my parents up
until the last couple of months some
kind of vacuum I'm not Canadian problem
yeah you don't have a car track record
and a landlord usually have to pay your
landlord are earlier on time for two
years have a strong down payment and be
early and be steady on your job for two
years and then with no credit score you
can get the same mortgage you could get
with a credit score right and so I'm
just wondering what what should be my
step I've got I've got a good good solid
downpayment saved up and so I just need
to know I don't necessarily think I have
the time to wait you know six to 24
months for left pane right awesome cuz
I'm getting married in a couple of
months and we'll be having a baby and
rent is really expensive in my area here
where it's not as expensive as home
ownership that's true but the rent is
extremely high in the seattle market and
i'm worried about using too much of a
down payment and then not having enough
to do you have to use the down payment
to pay the rent then you can't afford to
buy a house because you can't pay the
payment i can't pay a rent payment you
can't buy a house payment dude mm-hmm
baby's on the way no oh okay all right
well okay I'm sorry
I could pay the rent I just yeah let's
see when they're for rule it it just I'm
very you know afraid of not afraid but
sound of wasting the money in my mind
it's not as I mean it is a waste if you
live a life of doing this for a decade
I'm suggesting patience the first thing
you have to do is get married set up
your house spend a year getting to know
each other you'll make a much wiser
decision buying a house after you've
been married a year it takes a year of
being married and a hot close to your
mother-in-law to buy that was a joke
dude okay you got to get to know each
other you got to hang some curtain rods
together and I mean it's just which
would cause a divorce in some households
so you know you just you just have to
work through some stuff and you're
better off to just take your time when
you're 30 you're going to be glad you
were patient not five years of rent but
one year and you've already paid a
little bit of rent now it sounds like
get with Churchill mortgage and they'll
lay out for you exactly what you got to
do to qualify for a mortgage with no
credit score don't go get into debt and
don't go buy a house right now just take
your time get married be married a year
then go buy a house this is the Dave
Ramsey show